Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是Marianne。在进入今天的话题之前，我想先告诉大家一个令人兴奋的消息。如果你曾经想过如何创造属于自己的收入，而不是不断地用时间换取金钱，那么你一定会喜欢我商业导师Lisa Johnson发起的“通往经常性收入挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是立志成为心理学家、心理健康专业人士，还是来自完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up today, we are diving back in for a look at the role of clinical associate
这些原则都同样适用。此外，还有机会赢取由Lisa本人提供的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，还有机会赢取与我——Marianne Trent博士进行一对一辅导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。请前往我的Linktree页面“Dr. Marianne Trent”，查看我的社交媒体频道，或者直接给我发私信，我会为你提供所有详细信息。好了，让我们开始今天的节目吧。今天，我们将深入探讨临床心理学副手（Clinical Associate Psychologist）的角色。
psychologists. What is it? How do you train? Do you get paid? All the details you need to know. I hope you find it so useful. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent. I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. Now we are going to be chatting today with a fellow qualified clinical psychologist who has a very different role to me and I just love the diversity of the profession. Hope that you will find this really useful. We have spoken about the role of clinical associate psychologist before. That was about two years ago with Elise Dyer, and we were speaking about children and young people. So if you might find that episode helpful, please do dig that out. Otherwise, I hope you find this really useful and I look forward to
它是什么？如何进行培训？有薪水吗？你需要了解的所有细节都在这里。希望这对你有所帮助。你好，欢迎收听《有抱负的心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist podcast）。我是Marianne Trent博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。今天我们将与另一位合格的临床心理学家交谈，她的角色与我非常不同，我非常喜欢这个职业的多样性。希望你会觉得这期节目非常有用。我们之前讨论过临床心理学副手的角色，那大约是两年前与Elise Dyer的对话，当时我们讨论的是儿童和青少年。如果你觉得那期节目有帮助，请务必找出来听听。否则，希望你觉得今天的内容同样有用，我期待在
catching up with you at the end of this. Hi, just want to welcome along our guest for today, Dr. Dawn Reeves. Hi, Dawn. thanks for joining us. Hi, you're welcome, it's nice to be here. Thank you for your time. So we're getting together today because you are a qualified clinical psychologist but also we're thinking today about your current role which is training clinical associate psychologists or CAPs as we kind of think of them in psychology? Yeah so I work in EPUT and we have a CAP apprenticeship training program and we run that in partnership with Essex University so it's an it's an 18-month program but just 12 months of those cover the academic aspect of the program and throughout those 18 months you should be on a work placement you're employed in an NHS usually it's an NHS setting and you're
节目最后与你交流。你好，欢迎今天的嘉宾Dawn Reeves博士。你好，Dawn，感谢你的加入。你好，不客气，很高兴来到这里。感谢你的时间。我们今天聚在一起是因为你不仅是一位合格的临床心理学家，而且我们今天还要探讨你目前的工作，即培训临床心理学副手（CAPs）？是的，我在EPUT工作，我们有一个CAP学徒培训项目，我们与埃塞克斯大学合作开展这个项目。这是一个为期18个月的项目，其中只有12个月涵盖学术部分，在这18个月里，你需要在工作岗位上实习，通常是在英国国家医疗服务体系（NHS）的环境中，并且由
supervised by a clinical psychologist. Great so always supervised by a clinical psychologist. Yes yeah I believe you can it can also be a registered psychologist so it could be that it'd be a counseling psychologist you need to i believe the stipulation is that you have to be hcpc registered as a practicing psychologist okay so we're looking for the practitioner psychologist so um you know sometimes when people are thinking i would love to be a clinical psychologist one day they can be dissuaded by being supervised by different discipline but i was actually supervised by a forensic psychologist as the role before i got onto training and so in my experience it's the practitioner psychologist element that's
临床心理学家进行督导。太棒了，所以一直是由临床心理学家督导吗？是的，我相信也可以是注册心理学家，比如咨询心理学家。据我所知，规定是你必须是HCPC注册的执业心理学家。好的，所以我们寻找的是执业心理学家。嗯，你知道，有时当人们想“我将来想成为一名临床心理学家”时，可能会因为被不同学科的人督导而感到气馁，但我自己在进入培训之前的角色就是由法医心理学家督导的。所以根据我的经验，执业心理学家的身份才是
really important rather than necessarily which discipline it is. Absolutely, yeah. So it's about being registered and recognised profession within psychology. Yeah. Could you, just before we kind of really think and delve deep into the CAP role and your role within that, could you tell us a little bit about your background, how you got into psychology and where you trained, those sort of things, if that feels okay. Okay, so way, way back as an undergraduate student, I went to Brunel University and back then they used to run a very thin sandwich undergraduate degree, which would be six months study and six months work placement. You did that for three years and then your final fourth year was b1 academic year so there were often a lot of placements for prisons or student psychologists in prison so i worked in a prison for about six months on a sex offender treatment
最重要的，而不一定非要是哪个具体的学科。绝对是这样。所以关键在于成为心理学领域内注册并受认可的专业人士。是的。在深入探讨CAP角色以及你在其中的工作之前，你能简单介绍一下你的背景、你是如何进入心理学领域以及在哪里接受培训的吗？好的，很久以前，作为一名本科生，我去了布鲁内尔大学。当时他们开设了一种非常紧凑的“三明治”课程，即六个月学习和六个月实习。你这样做了三年，最后第四年是学术年。当时有很多针对监狱或监狱学生心理学家的实习机会，所以我曾在监狱工作了大约六个月，参与性犯罪者治疗
program so that gave me an insight into that kind of more um I suppose, clinical work, but I did most of the assessment work. So when I graduated, I wanted to work in that area, but I didn't manage to be successful in getting through the selection process for working in the prison service because back then it would be a master's programme. Then I thought about doing educational psychology. At that point, my psychology degree didn't have enough maths, I believe was their point, about why I couldn't train as a teacher, which you needed to do to be an educational psychologist.
项目。这让我对那种更偏向临床的工作有了深入了解，但我主要做的是评估工作。所以毕业后，我想在那个领域工作，但没能成功通过监狱系统的选拔程序，因为当时那需要硕士学位。然后我考虑过从事教育心理学。当时，我的心理学学位数学学分不够，我想这就是他们认为我不能接受教师培训的原因，而那是成为教育心理学家的必要条件。
And then I started to apply for assistant psychology posts so I managed to get one of those and learnt about how you could apply for clinical training from other assistants that I was working with so I gave that a shot and I was very lucky that I actually got accepted on a course, a Salomon's course, my first application. So I think a large part of that was because I had done that work in the prison service and in another placement on a third year I'd also worked in educational psychology department so I had that sort of work experience before I actually graduated which I think made a difference um so yeah after I finished my doctorate I worked and specialized with older people so I've worked in different community mental health teams some in London, Leicester and in Bedfordshire and I've always been involved in
然后我开始申请心理学助理职位，我成功获得了一个职位，并从一起工作的其他助理那里了解了如何申请临床培训。所以我尝试了一下，我很幸运，第一次申请就被Salomons课程录取了。我认为很大一部分原因是我在监狱服务部门做过那份工作，而且在第三年的另一个实习中，我也在教育心理学部门工作过，所以我毕业前就有那种工作经验，我认为这产生了影响。嗯，是的，在我完成博士学位后，我专门从事老年人心理健康工作，曾在伦敦、莱斯特和贝德福德郡的多个社区心理健康团队工作。我一直参与
some level of sort of teaching or education when I was a qualified psychologist I sort of would do some of the what they call honorary lecturing in doctorate psychology courses and give some workshops on older people and mental health because that was my specialty. And I worked for a time in Saudi Arabia for a couple of years on a clinical psychology program there helping to develop that so does that give a good summary it really does what a varied career you've had and you know I just I never I've never stopped getting blown away by you know the variety people have within their career and I can just imagine all of these different experiences just, you know, crystallising in your brain as kind of experience, you know,
某种程度的教学或教育工作。当我成为合格的心理学家后，我会做一些所谓的博士心理学课程的荣誉讲师工作，并举办一些关于老年人和心理健康的研讨会，因为那是我的专长。我还曾在沙特阿拉伯工作过几年，参与那里的临床心理学项目，帮助开发该项目。这个总结够全面吗？确实非常全面，你的职业生涯真是丰富多彩。你知道，我从未停止对人们职业生涯多样性的惊叹。我可以想象所有这些不同的经历都在你的大脑中结晶为经验，你知道，
working in kind of forensic services and then working in Saudi, such novel but important things that you learn so much about working with people, working with systems, working with teams, working about with clinical populations. You know, we really do do such varied work, don't we, in our profession? Absolutely. There won't ever be, I don't think there's ever a repetitive day. And I think that's what, for me, made psychology attractive and probably what's kept me in the role for this long is that I don't feel one week is the same to the next week and you
在法医服务部门工作，然后去沙特工作，这些新颖但重要的经历让你学到了很多关于与人、系统、团队以及临床人群打交道的知识。你知道，我们的职业确实做了很多样化的工作，不是吗？绝对是。我不认为会有重复的一天。我认为这就是心理学对我而言具有吸引力的地方，也可能是让我坚持这么久的原因，因为我觉得没有哪一周和下一周是完全一样的，而且你
can get involved in or be asked as well to get involved into so many pieces of work educational work training work there's research there's therapeutic work there's staff work and teams work organizational work so you can sort of find where your interests lie um i think it's not a dull job i don't think i don't know what you think oh it's not at all no i agree and i think people that often don't understand what we do in clinical psychology might say isn't it just loads of people moaning all the time and I'm like no it's not that even when you're doing kind of therapy or direct work with clients it's not that it isn't that like if that's all it is then you're not doing your role properly like you know it's not a it's not a passive process is it should be really active and you should be constantly trying to, in my experience, constantly trying to kind of fit a bespoke approach for this client, which means that it's a very active process for the professional, but also a really active dynamic process for the client.
可以参与或被要求参与很多工作：教育工作、培训工作、研究、治疗工作、员工工作、团队工作、组织工作，所以你可以找到自己的兴趣所在。嗯，我认为这不是一份枯燥的工作，不知道你怎么看？哦，一点也不，我同意。而且我认为那些不了解临床心理学工作的人可能会说：“那不就是整天听人抱怨吗？”我会说：“不，根本不是那样。”即使你在做治疗或与客户进行直接工作，也不是那样。如果仅仅是那样，那你就没有做好你的角色。你知道，这不是一个被动的过程，它应该是非常主动的，根据我的经验，你应该不断地尝试为这位客户量身定制方案，这意味着对于专业人士来说，这是一个非常主动的过程，对于客户来说，也是一个非常活跃和动态的过程。
It isn't just a venting space to go and moan. Like, in my experience, that's not at all the case yeah you've got you've i mean if you're going to get anything out of psychology you have to put something in don't you i mean i think a large part of a lot of psychologists they are kind of trainers and teachers because they're trying to help when you're doing individual work individuals learn different ways of doing things to try and help with whatever situation has brought them to your your service so yeah lovely so tell us about um your current role then um kind of working with with trainee caps okay so um the cap role is relatively new.
这不仅仅是一个发泄和抱怨的空间。根据我的经验，根本不是这样。是的，如果你想从心理学中获得什么，你就必须投入一些东西，不是吗？我的意思是，我认为很多心理学家在很大程度上也是培训师和教师，因为当你进行个人工作时，你是在帮助个人学习不同的做事方式，以尝试帮助他们解决带到你服务机构的任何情况。所以，太棒了。那么，告诉我们你目前的工作，即与CAP实习生一起工作的情况。好的，CAP角色相对较新。
And I work in an NHS trust, EPUT, and we have created a CAP apprenticeship program. What does that stand for, Dawn? What does EPUT stand for? Essex Partnership University Trust. Thank you. I work in a training department, so they've developed the MSc for the CAP, Clinical Associate in Psychology. That's in partnership with Essex University. So I have worked on that programme since it began.
我在一家NHS信托机构EPUT工作，我们创建了一个CAP学徒项目。Dawn，CAP代表什么？EPUT代表什么？埃塞克斯伙伴关系大学信托（Essex Partnership University Trust）。谢谢。我在培训部门工作，所以他们为CAP（临床心理学副手）开发了理学硕士课程。这是与埃塞克斯大学合作的。所以我从该项目开始就一直参与其中。
And I'd say we're developing it with each cohort we're now on coming up to cohort five we um we started with focusing on adult mental health caps so they were in placements in sort of nh NHS adult focus services. And for us, that was across Essex and Hertfordshire. So it's not necessary that you have to have worked in EPIRT, Essex Partnership University Trust, but it's kind of around geographically which programmes nearby because there's quite a few programmes around the country now. So I've helped with setting up the CAPS program.
我想说，我们每一届都在不断发展，现在即将迎来第五届。我们最初专注于成人心理健康CAP，所以他们在NHS成人重点服务机构实习。对我们来说，这覆盖了埃塞克斯和赫特福德郡。所以你不一定非要在EPUT工作，但这取决于地理位置，因为现在全国有很多这样的项目。所以我参与了CAP项目的建立。
I initially started with being a module lead for developing one of the modules which was on assessment formulation and presentation. I'm currently a deputy lead on that program, so that can involve lots of different roles, helping continue to develop the course, be a course tutor. So you work with CAPs and their placement supervisors, which is actually quite an important part of the CAP programme. You have to have...
我最初担任模块负责人，负责开发其中一个模块，内容是关于评估、构思和陈述。我目前是该项目的副负责人，这涉及许多不同的角色，帮助持续开发课程，担任课程导师。所以你要与CAP及其实习督导合作，这实际上是CAP项目非常重要的一部分。你必须有……
Yep, so there's a tripartite review that has to be scheduled for every 12 weeks during the 18-month program. And that's done with the student, the clinical supervisor, and the course tutor. So that's just to keep an eye on what's going on in placement how the student is progressing in learning objectives through their workplace and adjusting for any issues that might that might be coming up as well that sounds really important it was bringing back slightly horrifying memories of being a trainee and having mid-placement reviews and you know that question where it gets asked is there any chance that the trainee could fail this placement is it that kind of thing like but you're doing every 12 weeks it is yeah and the 12 weeks is to you know if there are any
是的，在18个月的项目期间，每12周必须安排一次三方审查。这是由学生、临床督导和课程导师共同完成的。这只是为了关注实习期间的情况，了解学生在工作场所的学习目标进展如何，并针对可能出现的任何问题进行调整。这听起来非常重要。这让我想起了作为实习生时那种稍微有点恐怖的记忆，比如进行实习中期评估，你知道那个被问到的问题：“实习生有失败的可能吗？”就是那种感觉，但你们每12周就做一次。是的，12周是为了，你知道，如果有什么
early indications that the placement might not be going well it's about figuring out what we can do about that because something that can come up is about opportunities for learning. So if a student, but most of the time it's students and supervisors, find that maybe there's not as many cases available to them to carry out some of the objectives that they need to complete for their training. So we can think through what other opportunities there might be I mean so is it be better to give an idea so if we for instance have a student who's working in an assessment only service a part of the CAP trainings you have to do some amount of intervention work you have to learn intervention skills so it might be that that's difficult for a supervisor and the
早期迹象表明实习可能进展不顺利，就要弄清楚我们能做些什么。因为可能出现的一个问题是关于学习机会。如果学生——但大多数时候是学生和督导——发现可能没有足够的案例让他们完成培训所需的某些目标，我们就可以思考还有什么其他机会。我的意思是，举个例子，如果我们有一个在纯评估服务机构工作的学生，CAP培训的一部分是你必须进行一定量的干预工作，你必须学习干预技能，所以督导和学生可能很难接触到这些案例，所以我们可以利用这样的会议来思考如何实现这一点。
student to access those sort of cases so we can use meetings like that to think about how that can be done great thank you and what what is involved in a typical kind of trainee or even for that matter qualified CAP intervention what might be typical? Gosh I don't think there would be a typical because it really depends on the service so CAPS I think that's the distinguishing part about CAPS training is they're trained into a service so if you think about clinical psychology doctorate, you get trained. Typically, you will be trained in different sort of services across those three years. You'll be having usually a six month placement and coming in and out. I know some courses now, the placements are for a bit longer, but typically it would be about six months. So with the CAP, they're in one service, they're employed in the service, and it's the hope is that that CAP would continue in that service once they've qualified. So the service is training them up to be, you know, skilled in that particular area of work.
太棒了，谢谢。那么，典型的实习生甚至合格的CAP干预工作涉及什么？典型的会是什么样？天哪，我不认为会有典型的，因为它真的取决于服务机构。所以CAP，我认为这是CAP培训的区别所在，他们是针对特定服务进行培训的。如果你想想临床心理学博士学位，你接受的是通用培训。通常，你会在那三年里在不同的服务机构接受培训。你通常会有六个月的实习，进进出出。我知道现在有些课程的实习时间长一点，但通常是六个月左右。而对于CAP，他们在一个服务机构，受雇于该服务机构，希望CAP在获得资格后能继续留在该服务机构。所以服务机构正在培训他们，使他们成为该特定工作领域的熟练人员。
So you can think that the different services that we have our CAP students in at the moment can be learning disability services, adult mental health services, health psychology services. We've got some older adult services, autism assessment services. So it's a real mix. So each CAP is going to have a very different experience of their training from the perspective of their actual placement. Although the learning objectives are all going to be the same. So each placement has to meet specific learning objectives set out by the apprenticeship standards and BPS standards as well. Great. Thank you for that. And am I right in thinking that it's not only is it a master's programme, but it's also a funded programme as well. Great thank you for that and am I right in thinking that it's not only is it a
所以你可以想到，我们目前的CAP学生所在的不同服务机构可能是学习障碍服务、成人心理健康服务、健康心理学服务。我们还有一些老年人服务、自闭症评估服务。所以这真的是多种多样。因此，从实际实习的角度来看，每个CAP的培训经历都会非常不同。尽管学习目标都是一样的。所以每个实习都必须满足学徒标准和英国心理学会（BPS）标准设定的特定学习目标。太棒了，谢谢。我理解得对吗？这不仅是一个硕士课程，而且还是一个资助项目。
master's program but it's also a funded program as well so you get paid to do your master's and paid to do your training so it really is incredible as an opportunity for people. Yes so it's a fully paid master's apprenticeship so the apprenticeship part of it is where the funding comes from so your master's is paid for you're not paying for the master's and you're in paid employment you are employed by the trust that you are in a placement with so you're not employed by for instance EPIRT the NHS trust that's providing this training program, for instance, the one I work with, you're employed by your service that you're working into. So yeah, you're employed at a band five, perhaps I should say that as well. So as an apprentice, you'll be employed a band five.
是的，这是一个全额资助的硕士学徒项目，所以学徒部分就是资金来源，你的硕士学位费用由机构支付，你不需要支付硕士学费，而且你是在带薪就业，你受雇于你实习所在的信托机构。所以你不是受雇于EPUT（提供此培训项目的NHS信托机构），而是受雇于你工作的服务机构。所以是的，你以五级（Band 5）身份受雇，也许我也应该提一下。作为学徒，你将以五级身份受雇。
Once you qualify as a CAP, you should then go up to be employed as a band six. In terms of thinking about where someone's level will remain, there's no reason why, for instance, as a CAP, you wouldn't then perhaps progress into the banding once you're qualified, but that would depend obviously on further training in England. As far as I know in Wales, I think they've recently started or they're developing their CAPS training program. And I believe they're going to start working at band seven once they're qualified.
一旦你获得CAP资格，你就应该晋升为六级（Band 6）员工。至于某人的级别会保持在哪里，没有理由说，例如，作为一名CAP，你在获得资格后不能晋升到更高的级别，但这显然取决于英国的进一步培训。据我所知，在威尔士，他们最近开始了或正在开发他们的CAP培训项目。我相信他们获得资格后将从七级（Band 7）开始工作。
So there is some variation in the different regions. But in England, you would start at band six once you're qualified. Right. It's so brilliant and actually in terms of you know diversity and inclusion and reducing inequality in psychology if you know because a master's is not a cheap thing you know and if you're then not able to if you're not able to work either because you're studying for your master's it's it's really difficult so this is a really wonderful way of people being able to access higher education. And they may choose to stay as a CAP, you know, that might just be,
所以不同地区确实存在一些差异。但在英国，你获得资格后将从六级开始。太棒了。实际上，在多样性和包容性以及减少心理学领域的不平等方面，你知道，因为硕士学位并不便宜，如果你因为要攻读硕士学位而无法工作，那真的很困难，所以这对于人们获得高等教育来说是一个非常好的途径。他们可能会选择留在CAP岗位上，你知道，那可能只是，
I guess that's the trust's hope that they will just stay as a qualified CAP, really. But it's such a brilliant and inclusive way of being able to access a master's qualification. Yes, I mean, I think services are very different as well in what they're doing with their caps once they qualify so yeah absolutely services would like them to stay and work as a cap but I know that services are actually investing in their qualified caps as well and providing access to further training so there's more specialist training. There is a limit when you're qualifying as a cap because it's an NHS England funded apprenticeship. That means that you can't access any further NHS funded training for another two years once you qualify.
我想那是信托机构的希望，希望他们能留下来作为合格的CAP工作。但这确实是一种获得硕士学位的绝佳且包容的方式。是的，我的意思是，我认为服务机构在CAP获得资格后的做法也非常不同。所以是的，绝对地，服务机构希望他们留下来作为CAP工作，但我知道服务机构实际上也在投资他们的合格CAP，并提供进一步培训的机会，所以有更专业的培训。当你获得CAP资格时，确实有一个限制，因为这是NHS英格兰资助的学徒项目。这意味着你获得资格后的两年内不能再获得任何NHS资助的培训。
But if you were to pay for a course yourself or if your service decided to pay for it and budget for that, you could still go and do it. So you're not restricted in that way. But there's a limit, you know, there's a limit in terms of the amount of funding you can get from the NHS. I hope that makes sense. It really does. It really does. Yes. So in 2020, it was announced by Health Education England that that limit would be around. And it was almost around immediately but there was some petitioning done it was led by Erkan White who was a an aspiring psychologist at the time and is now a trainee and that was overhauled and delayed for a couple of years but
但如果你自己付费参加课程，或者你的服务机构决定支付并为此预算，你仍然可以去参加。所以你并没有受到那样的限制。但有一个限制，你知道，从NHS获得的资金总额是有限的。希望这说得通。确实说得通。是的。所以2020年，英国健康教育局（Health Education England）宣布了这一限制。它几乎立即生效，但有人请愿，由当时的一位有抱负的心理学家Erkan White领导，他现在是一名实习生，该政策被彻底审查并推迟了几年，但
certainly that is in force now. So in the beginning we had some caps that that didn't apply to. So they were able to, I believe, access funding sooner. But the caps that are on training now, there's that two year limit. Yeah. And if things don't go well, you know, do people sometimes choose to stop in the middle of their training? Or sometimes do they not meet the criteria? So they're in the middle of their training or sometimes do they not meet the criteria so they're in essence kind of retired from the system has that happened so far yes i mean there is flexibility within the apprenticeship rules you can actually take a break in learning so if you find that whatever circumstances are going on that mean you can't carry on with your training at the moment. It could be through health or life circumstances.
现在肯定已经生效了。所以起初我们有一些CAP不受此限制。所以他们能够，我相信，更快地获得资助。但现在正在接受培训的CAP，有两年的限制。是的。如果事情进展不顺利，你知道，人们有时会选择在培训中途停止吗？或者有时他们没有达到标准？所以他们在培训中途，或者有时他们没有达到标准，所以他们本质上是被系统“退休”了，这种情况发生过吗？是的，我的意思是学徒规则中有灵活性，你实际上可以暂停学习。所以如果你发现无论发生什么情况，意味着你目前无法继续培训。可能是因为健康或生活状况。
It could be the placement itself. You can actually request a break in learning. And we have had examples of that. And I believe you can have a break up to 12 months, up to a year. Typically, you know, the person will carry on working in some capacity, just not in that cap role. And then you can come back into the program at the point at which you left. So in terms of the learning stage that you left, you will have to, in those situations, make your own efforts to find a new placement. So the course could help give you advice and guidance, but ultimately the student is the one that would be responsible for looking to see what other CAP apprenticeships are being advertised and to apply for those and hopefully be successful and the advantage for those employing services are that this CAP student
可能是实习本身的问题。你实际上可以申请暂停学习。我们有这样的例子。我相信你可以休息长达12个月，长达一年。通常，你知道，这个人会以某种身份继续工作，只是不在那个CAP角色中。然后你可以在你离开的地方回到项目中。所以就你离开的学习阶段而言，在这种情况下，你必须自己努力寻找新的实习机会。所以课程可以帮助提供建议和指导，但最终学生本人有责任寻找其他正在招聘的CAP学徒职位并申请，希望能够成功。对于那些雇佣服务机构来说，优势在于这个CAP学生
won't have to take as long to finish because they would have done part of their CAP training before then. Yeah so there's some flexibility much like any sort of educational program you can actually take breaks in learning so that's in a way that's been quite a revelation to me because I never knew these things when I wasn't working in education. So if, for example, a trainee clinical psychologist started year one or year two and were driving hours and hours and hours of placement each day and they thought that might be sustainable. But it obviously we know that that was always going to be a tricky ask there isn't that flexibility to example you know move from an edinburgh course to a leicester course at the moment um because they're entirely separate and that's really tricky because when you're deciding to leave a trainee psychologist role you're essentially saying i'm i'm done or i will start again somewhere else and it sounds like there's
不需要花那么长时间就能完成，因为他们之前已经完成了部分CAP培训。是的，所以有一定的灵活性，就像任何教育项目一样，你实际上可以暂停学习，所以这对我来说算是一个启示，因为我在教育领域工作之前从未听说过这些。所以，如果例如，一名临床心理学实习生开始了第一年或第二年，每天开车数小时去实习，他们认为这可能是可持续的。但我们显然知道这总是一个棘手的要求，目前没有那种灵活性，例如从爱丁堡课程转到莱斯特课程，因为它们是完全独立的，这真的很棘手，因为当你决定离开实习心理学家角色时，你本质上是在说“我放弃了”或者“我会在别处重新开始”，听起来CAP实习生角色有
more flexibility in a trainee cap role yes i think there's i mean i don't know of any examples where people have actually switched from one program to another but it is possible in theory because each program is having to follow the same like learning objectives it's quite a specific expectations from the apprenticeship side and the bps side of what actually they need to learn so i guess it would be more difficult if they were being trained in one of the more specialist areas you know like learn disabilities or older adults or health if they then tried to work get back into a program that was mainly adult focused um i'm not sure if there are any other courses that have had this happen yet, but I'm sure there's room for precedent. I think it would be more easy to come back into the same
更多的灵活性。是的，我想有。我的意思是，我不知道有人从一个项目转到另一个项目的例子，但在理论上是可能的，因为每个项目都必须遵循相同的学习目标。学徒方面和BPS方面对于他们实际需要学习的内容有非常具体的要求。所以我猜如果他们在更专业的领域接受培训，比如学习障碍、老年人或健康，如果他们试图回到一个主要以成人为重点的项目中，那会更困难。我不确定是否还有其他课程发生过这种情况，但我相信有先例的空间。我认为回到同一个
course, but having taken a break and changing workplace. So we definitely have an example of that in our programme. Somebody's taken a break and then come back in later on in a new placement. Great. Thank you. And just before we finish, have you got any of your top tips, like even just a top tip for how to reduce burnout in aspiring psychologists? Because we do ask a lot of our aspiring psychologists at times, don't we? So I would say to bear in mind that psychology is not everything i know when a person is younger or when they're quite focused on an ambition and um have like really clear plans of how they're going to get there um it can kind of take over a bit because it is a it can be a
课程会更容易，但需要休息并更换工作场所。所以我们的项目中肯定有这样的例子。有人休息了一段时间，后来在新的实习岗位上又回来了。太棒了。谢谢。在结束之前，你有什么秘诀吗？哪怕只是一个关于如何减少有抱负的心理学家职业倦怠的秘诀？因为我们有时确实对有抱负的心理学家要求很高，不是吗？所以我会说要记住心理学并不是一切。我知道当一个人年轻时，或者当他们非常专注于某个目标时，并且有非常明确的计划如何实现它，它可能会占据主导地位，因为它是一个
very challenging uh profession to get into. But I would say to everybody, don't give up. You know, if that's really what you want to do, stay focused on it. But, you know, enjoy other aspects of your life as well. Psychologists are better when they're more rounded people and when they have particular interests in certain areas. So that's going to help you have a longer career if you aren't just solely focused on psychology
非常有挑战性的职业。但我会告诉所有人，不要放弃。你知道，如果那真的是你想做的事，保持专注。但是，你知道，也要享受生活的其他方面。心理学家在成为更全面的人，并且在某些领域有特定兴趣时会表现得更好。所以如果你不仅仅专注于心理学，这将有助于你拥有更长的职业生涯。
in all the things you do. So I would say you've got to have, looking after your health in terms of physical health, looking after your mental health in terms of well-being keep good friends you know have hobbies a range of things that you're interested in it also makes you I think it makes you a good practitioner too if you've got other things that you're involved in it certainly helps with conversation you know if you're a well-rounded person you're going to be able to
在你所做的一切事情中。所以我认为你必须拥有，在身体健康方面照顾好自己，在心理健康方面照顾好自己的幸福感，保持好朋友，你知道，有爱好，有一系列你感兴趣的事情。我认为如果你参与了其他事情，这也会让你成为一名优秀的从业者。这肯定有助于对话，你知道，如果你是一个全面发展的人，你将能够
that your clients are going to are going to get that impression you're going to find a relationship building a lot easier I hope that answers the question it really does yeah you've got to be a human first and a psychologist second haven't you and it's about being personable because you know those conversations where you're walking from from reception to clinic room you know it's about being personable because you know those conversations where you're walking from from reception to clinic room you know that's where you're supposed to be a little bit more natural a little bit more human um and I I don't know what your experiences are but I found since the pandemic that there's been much more person in clinicians because it's really been a leveling experience that really does put us all kind of in a similar position of uncertainty and threat and menace and and all of that and that that really
你的客户会得到那种印象，你会发现建立关系容易得多。希望这回答了这个问题。确实回答了。是的，你必须先是一个人，其次才是心理学家，不是吗？而且要平易近人，因为你知道那些从接待处走到诊室的谈话，你知道，那是你应该表现得更自然、更人性化一点的地方。我不知道你的经历是什么，但我发现自疫情以来，临床医生变得更加人性化了，因为这确实是一种平等的经历，它确实把我们都置于一种相似的不确定性、威胁和危险的境地，而那确实
did affect it i think yeah everybody that i've spoken to has sort of said yeah it is it is different now it is just a bit different i think it gave people the time to reflect on you know what people say the work-life balance work-life home balance family relationships downtime um how important it is to keep that balance going because if you're giving too much at work you're not you haven't got that time to recharge yourself um you're going to be a better clinician for your clients and you're going to be a better colleague for your people you work with um if you've got that sort of balance um it's not always going to be perfect but if you've got it in mind of why it's important to keep it going um that's going to help you a long way from trying to protect yourself from
影响了它，我想。是的，我交谈过的每个人都说：“是的，现在确实不同了。”它就是有点不同。我认为它给了人们时间去反思，你知道人们所说的“工作-生活平衡”、“工作-家庭平衡”、家庭关系、休息时间，保持这种平衡是多么重要。因为如果你在工作中付出太多，你就没有时间给自己充电。如果你有那种平衡，你将成为客户更好的临床医生，也将成为同事更好的工作伙伴。这并不总是完美的，但如果你心里明白为什么保持这种平衡很重要，那将对你保护自己免受
burnout and always take your annual leave as well that would be another thing i say i mean annual leave is there for you to take at regular points i know it's easy to think you know you just want to um keep it for like one long chunk but my my advice would be, you know, take bits of time off regularly throughout the whole year and do something that's completely unrelated to your work, unrelated to psychology. Have some fun. Recharge that aspect of yourself that's not the psychologist. Yeah, I so agree. Such brilliant advice. Thank you so much for your time in speaking with us today, Dawn. It's been a really, really interesting, insightful episode. You're welcome. I hope it can give some of your
职业倦怠有很大帮助。另外，一定要休年假，这也是我会说的另一件事。我的意思是，年假是为了让你在定期的时间点休息。我知道很容易认为你只想把它留作一大块时间，但我的建议是，在全年定期休假，做一些与你的工作完全无关、与心理学无关的事情。找点乐子。给那个不是心理学家的自己充电。是的，我非常同意。真是太棒的建议了。非常感谢你今天抽出时间与我们交谈，Dawn。这是一期非常、非常有意思且富有洞察力的节目。不客气。我希望它能给你的
listeners, your viewers, some confidence and encouragement to keep going with, you know, their ideas about becoming a psychologist and where they can perhaps train in different roles, different psychological roles. Absolutely, it absolutely will do. Thank you again. You're welcome. Thank you for watching and thank you so much for my guest time talking through this important area which I really do think is an exciting development for psychology. So it has been around a few years now, but hopefully it will become a really viable and enjoyable career for people and not just seen as a hop step and a jump to be able to get on to do a doctorate. I'd love to know what you think about this. Has this inspired you to look
听众、观众一些信心和鼓励，让他们继续坚持关于成为心理学家的想法，以及他们可以在哪里接受不同角色、不同心理学角色的培训。绝对会，肯定会的。再次感谢。不客气。感谢收看，也非常感谢我的嘉宾抽出时间来讨论这个重要的领域，我确实认为这是心理学领域一个令人兴奋的发展。所以它已经存在几年了，但希望它能成为人们真正可行且令人愉快的职业，而不仅仅被视为进入博士课程的跳板。我很想知道你对此有何看法。这是否激励了你去寻找
for trainee cap roles? Do come and let me know in the Aspiring Psychologist community free Facebook group. I'd also love it if you take a moment to rate and review us on either Apple podcasts or Spotify, as that helps the podcast to be reaching a wider audience. Whatever time of year it is, it's always a good time to dive into the books Clinical Psychologist Collective and the Aspiring Psychologist Collective 2. Thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to bringing the next episode to you which will be available from 10am on Saturdays on YouTube and from 6am on Mondays as an mp3. Thank you again and be kind to yourselves. With this podcast at your side, you'll be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent.
CAP实习生职位？欢迎来到“有抱负的心理学家社区”免费Facebook群组告诉我。如果你能花点时间在Apple Podcasts或Spotify上为我们评分和评论，我也会非常感激，因为这有助于播客触及更广泛的受众。无论一年中的什么时候，现在都是阅读《临床心理学家集体》（Clinical Psychologist Collective）和《有抱负的心理学家集体2》（Aspiring Psychologist Collective 2）的好时机。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待着为你带来下一期节目，该节目将于周六上午10点在YouTube上发布，并于周一上午6点以mp3格式发布。再次感谢，请善待自己。有这个播客在身边，你离获得资格就不远了。这是《有抱负的心理学家播客》，我是Marianne Trent博士。
My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我叫Jana，是一名心理健康实习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集体》这本书。我发现关于所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的内容非常有趣。各种各样的途径让我感到惊讶，成为一名心理学家没有完美的道路，这让我充满了信心，不再觉得我做错了，也减轻了我的压力。所以如果你对成为临床心理学家感到有点不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，一旦开始读，你就停不下来。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。